صباح الخير صبايا شلونكم طبعا
السمك المسقوف ذكر الباحث العراقي والمختص
يعني
التنقيبات والابحاث السومريه والمؤرخ فوزي
رشيد انه السمك المسبوق طريقه اعداده ذكرت
على الرفاع البابليه القديمه والرقاع
السومريه القديمه ايضا العراقيين اللي
يسكنون على ضفاف الانهار خاصه في محافظه
ذي قار كانوا يصيدون السنه خاصه الرجال
ويصنعون بطريقه المسد نفس الطريقه اللي
اليوم يعني يتم بها اعداد السمك بعد صيد
السمك يتم شوائه المسجد لكن على اي رجال
المصادقه اليوم انه الشخص اللي راح يعني
اعز السمكه المسقوفه الامراه الوحيده
بالعراق
هي ام علي على ايدها يعني حتى بالمطاعم
وبالمنازل العراقيه نلاحظ انه الرجال هم
اللي يعدون السمك حسب المنزل
يعني اعداد السمك المذبوق صار كم سنه
وشلون الناس يتعاملة عراقيه تعدي سمك
[موسيقى]
اني اعرف بشوي فتحي للمحل
بعدين هو توقف
طبعا ايضا الشبكه المزبوط يعني لازال يعد
بالطريقه البدائيه اللي هي تفتح السمكه
تنظف وتملح وتشوى مباشره على الحطب لكن
مثل ما يقولون الطبيعه هي التي يعني تضيف
المطيبات لهذا السمك اللي هو الحطب نفسه
اللي يستخدم فوائد السمك هو اللي يضيف هاي
المطيبات له فام علي تتحدثين لانه اكو
انواع من الحطب يعني معينه تستخدم لاعداد
السمك وهي تعتبر مطيبات لهذا السمك دون
استخدام توابل
بس القلم خاص كلش طيب يعني الليمون داعشي
شفته بالسمك يعني اكو انواع من الاخشاب
التي تستخدم لاعداد السمك المذبوح اللي هي
من اشجار او اشجار الصفصاف او اشجار
الليمون ايضا ايضا سمك المزبوط يعني من
الاسماك حضرتش تستخدميها ممكن تتحدثين عن
السمكه السوداء
القدماء ايضا قالوا عن السلف انه يعني هو
يعتبر بديل الدواء وايضا هو يعني مصلح
للاعضاء فذكروا يعني ذكروا فوائد كثيره عن
السمك يا سهام ونادين فاذا تحبون مثلا
تسالون ضيفه سؤال ثانية
زينب سمعتينا
اسمعكم زينب انا اليوم دوري اسالك سؤال
لماذا سمي بسمك المسقوف يعني ترجمه لماذا
ما واضح
حقيقه لكن الطريقه التي
سمع دواء على الحطب فقط تقطع يقطع الحطب
من الاشجار ويوضع السمك بطريقه دائريه
يعني
الشبكات بطريقه دائريه ويوضع الحطب بالوسط
الشخص اللي يشوي السمك هو اللي يتحكم
بالنار يعني اذا تكون قريبه او بعيده عن
السمكه لازم تكون نار بطريقه يعني متوازنه
جدا حتى السمكه تحتوي على نار هادئه
وتصوي بطريقه يعني جيده يعني صحيح بسبب
اليه الطهي يعني واليه شوي السمك وانا نضف
الى ذلك بانها تاتي من سقف وهي كلمه في
اللغه الاراميه والاكاديه وطبعا بطريقه
وضع السمكه وشقها من الظهر
وتعليقها لشويها بالتالي هي مثقفه من
مسقوف شكرا زينب المشاط من بغداد مراسله
صباح العربيه وسيده المسقوف ام علي